hi my name is alia Lee Kong I'm a
Michelin star chef cookbook author a
chief culinary officer for real East
number shy Jenna's retired running back
with the New York Giants season 24 dance
with the Stars champ and New York Times
bestselling author and we're here to
pick our squad I'm about to pick our
all-time cheese from 49er squad my first
pick now listen this is a new area this
2020 high so first I need my quarterback
and I'm starting off with Patrick my own
there's no doubt about it I have to pick
him he's mobile because I'm putting
together a mastery team of mobility
second my running back is Marcus Allen
he can do it all catch out the backfield
he can run the rock get you those ugly
yards to next now this it might be a
little bit of surprise but I'm spreading
out to fill I'm gonna pick my tight end
I need somebody to open up the field for
Patrick my Holmes and I think a tight
end works very well at a time of
pressure you see how he does one of the
Great's plan right now then I'm gonna
add in Jerry Rice and all the time great
got to have somebody to out there on the
open end and open the field now for me
is because this is my team
all right I'm worried about the whole
entire offense I'm gonna add in a little
scat receiver as well this team right
here if you had a lineup and play
against these boys this is almost pretty
much the Super Bowl now how you see it
but if you had a lineup against this
team I don't I don't even think these
defensive guys could stop it so this is
my all-time 49ers and Kansas City's
lineup so my squad we got patching your
home's Patrick my homeboy
he'd probably get MVP of the Super Bowl
this year we got so many Gonzalez a
retired all the Famer all-time great
spreads out to fill Marcus Allen
one of a kind class hat guy also could
catch out the backfield and I think he
would fit in this eras game tremendously
we got Jerry Rice and spread out to fill
one of the greatest leaders all-time
leading receiver I think he would go
match well and get over the top will
patch him the home especially with Tyree
killed reading out at the top but
nobody's gonna be able to play cover
three against his defense and I think
it'll open up the offense from industry
my name is Rashad Jennings again and I'm
a lily Kong and we just built our squad